il ne s'agit pas de la première affaire
de ce genre en france sont se souvient
du concorde ski un tube paul f qui
ressemblait étrangement au supersonique
en 1968 en 1987 c'est un polytechnicien
français pierre verdier qui est
soupçonné d'avoir informé l'urss sur la
fusée ariane
et aujourd'hui encore les industries
françaises se protègent assez peu elles
sont pourtant très présente dans les
secteurs technologiques release castel
samuel beam il était la preuve vivante
d'une affaire d'espionnage
le même nez cassé pour ce type oled
supersonique qui passera deux mois avant
le concorde le mur du son mais le
copier-coller soviétique s'écrasera en
1973 concorde avait failli avoir un
concurrent
parce qu'en france disent les experts on
n'est pas assez vigilants c'est très
difficile très difficile de dire aux
gens votre emploi est peut-être lié au
secret industriel ou à la connaissance
de vos prospects commerciaux etc
il ya généré un manque d'intérêt dans la
population
je dirais qu'ils travaillent en france
sur ces questions-là en 1987
ariane avait failli subir le même sort
que concorde un polytechnicien français
pierre verdier son épouse d'origine
soviétique sont arrêtés ainsi que cinq
autres personnes toutes bénéficié aux
finalement d'un non lieu
les tensions entre l'est et l'ouest sont
alors importante
un physicien d'origine est allemande
travaillant au cnrs et condamné à 12 ans
de prison avant d'être acquitté
aujourd'hui lac ce n'est plus bipolaire
entre l'est et l'ouest
le danger vient de peut-être des pays
émergents qui rentre dans dans le
le commerce mondial qui ont une
appétence deux un appétit de
développement considérable et je le
disais tout à l'heure ce qui a changé
par rapport à l'air que nous évoquions
tout à l'heure de la guerre froide c'est
que aujourd'hui l'information la
connaissance devient le levier de la
concurrence le levier de la compétivité
aux yeux des américains
la france n'est cependant pas qu'une
victime il ya dix ans paris avait ainsi
demandé à washington de rappeler cinq
diplomates qui à notre goût surveiller
d'un peu trop près nos affaires
d'espionnage